c'est aux cris de vive l'empereur que
l'on franchit niemen ici à l'orée de ce
coude que fait le fleuve en face de la
ville de kovno en lituanie les feux du
soleil étincelles sur les baïonnettes et
les casques les troupes déborde
d'enthousiasmé
le spectacle est magnifique
nous sommes exactement l'endroit où se
tient à l'empereur napoléon le 24 juin
ces jours là le temps il super vous
comme aujourd'hui edit silva contempler
son armée en train de franchir le yémen
depuis la nature a repris ses droits
mais à l'époque la vue était
parfaitement dégagées d'ici au fleuve au
pied de napoléon le gros de son armée
c'est près de 5000 hommes qui vont
franchir le niémen et s'enfoncer dans le
plein russes à la recherche de l'armée
de kutuzov les sapeurs de la gare de
plein d'attentions pour leur empereur
lui avait construit un siège en
branchages avec un dea en feuilles et de
ce train d'improviser l'empereur va voir
le corps du maréchal davout avec la
division de morat en tête
passé le pont est à son tour il renonce
à cheval franchi le new men et s'est
dirigé vers comment à l'époque la ville
compte 5000 habitants blottie au pied du
vieux château de kovno qui servit de
dépôt à la con d'armer une plaque
rappelle que l'empereur installa ici son
quartier général au couvent des
carmélites de la sainte croix
c'est aujourd'hui une filature en 48
heures napoléon organise la défense de
kovno il veille aussi à ce que les
hôpitaux ne manque de rien et vérifie
l'approvisionnement des magasins aucun
détail de lui échappe
dans le même temps ses troupes marche
sur les traces des russes
perdu dans un écrin de verdure le vieux
château d'eau si ni sky a mal vécu les
années où il servit de tentes à la
culture socialiste
le 27 juin 1812 lorsque napoléon y
arrive pour y dormir c'est une propriété
superbe sur la route de vilna cinq jours
après avoir franchi niémen cinq jours
après le début des hostilités la
capitale de la lituanie est conquise
presque sans coup férir
il dit si napoléon découvre la ville de
l'ancien royaume de pologne que le tsar
alexandre et ses hommes viennent
d'évacuer dans la précipitation
les généraux russes bas gration et
barclays de taulis effectué leur
retraite par des routes divergentes
c'est par cette porte là porter hors que
l'empereur entrave ilna les habitants
lui font un accueil qu'il aurait aimé
plus chaleureux d'autant plus qu'ils
sont ravis d'être débarrassé des russes
napoléon va rester 18 jours à vilna il
est venu dans cet hôtel qui fut le
quartier général du prince eugène de
beauharnais 18 jours une longue halte
qu'il n'a pu éviter
l'armée a besoin de souffler maladie
épuisement ont quelque peu clairsemé les
rangs
pourtant tout a été prévu services de
santé ravitaillement munitions oui mais
voilà les troupes ont marché trop vite
et l'intendance n'arrive pas à suivre
durant son séjour napoléon s'installe
dans cette bâtisse l'ancien palais des
gouverneurs
aujourd'hui le palais présidentiel à
l'intérieur de ses murs il infléchit le
destin de la lituanie il lui donne une
administration distinctes et
indépendantes ce qui si grasse et les
dents des russes et il transforme vilna
en dépouille pour la grande armée
m
visitant la ville napoléon tomba en
arrêt ou plutôt en admiration devant
cette vieille église de briques rouges
l'église des bernardins je voudrais
dit-il pouvoir l'emporter dans le creux
de ma main
en quittant vilna napoléon veut empêcher
la jonction des deux armées russes et il
veut les battre séparément il espère qu
à vitebsk l'affrontement tant désirée
pour avoir lieu
albrech adam auteur de ce dessin suivent
l armée en campagne le crayon à la main
le 24 juillet 1812 avait 5o vici la
cavalerie légère bavaroise franchi la
douane a juste à cet endroit à la
poursuite des russes de barclays tholy
sur la route de vitebsk sur la rive-sud
de la drina le petit village de se
trouvent nos quelques maisons de bois
perdu dans la campagne là pour la
première fois les russes vont défendre
âprement le terrain à ma gauche le petit
village aux trombes d'eau c'est ici qu'a
eu lieu le 25 juillet 1812 le premier
grand d'engagement entre le gros de
l'armée française qui marchaient vers
itep sq et les corps de l'armée russe
qui défend des ces approches le 25
juillet au matin
la cavalerie française guidés par le roi
de naples paraissent de ce côté à la
tête de la galerie le 8e régiment des
hussards sous le commandement du colonel
demont à cet endroit là il y avait six
pièces d'artillerie à cheval russe les
hussards français n'ont pas hésité un
instant
il attaque les pièces ils sabrent les
canonniers ils renversent les escadrons
russe qui protège et l'artillerie
c'est comme ça qui a commencé le fameux
combat de straub nos qui a rouvert à
napoléon la route et harry teps qu ici
sur les bords de la drina qui mène à
vitebsk s'est déroulée une scène
d'anthologie
entouré de tout l'état majeur napoléon
est là sous ses yeux de l'autre côté de
ce ravin une poignée de voltigeur du 9e
régiment de ligne
assailli par la cavalerie russe on
tremble on frémit
on les croit perdu mais les voltigeurs
sortent sains et saufs de cette
effroyable mêlée qui êtes vous leur
demande l'empereur tous enfants de paris
et bien mes amis vous êtes des braves et
vous avez tous mérité la croix
8es puisque la vieille ville où
l'empereur a passé quinze jours n'existe
plus là encore en 1812
les russes ont déserté les lieux
napoléon se demande s'il n'est pas
préférable de consolider l'acquis et de
reprendre la campagne en 1813 et le 8
août
l'attak de nos avants postes le décide à
reprendre l'infernal poursuites
l'objectif est de déborder de tourner
les 140 pilotes de l'armée russe
aujourd'hui réunies autour de smolensk
la manoeuvre est pétri d'audace mais sur
la route de smolensk akhrass noyer murat
et sa cavalerie tombe sur les 6000
hommes de la division des vers au score
on en prix un tiers
une victoire à double tranchant car au
terme de cette journée
l'ennemi comprend qu'il lui faut
défendre l'antique cité de smolensk des
lancers muraille la peau leur est passé
de l'espoir la déception l'espoir parce
qu'ils espéraient tenir enfin sa
bataille
cette bataille qui devait résoudre le
sort de la campagne déception parce que
les 17 août il comprend que les généraux
russes ont continué à la retraite mais à
- barclay des tôles il ne pouvait pas
abandonner la ville sans donner le
combat au moins pour l'honneur
il a laissé ici trente mille soldats à
15 heures n'est pas leur donnent
l'assaut les sept divisions de la grande
armée s'élance à l'attack des faubourgs
qui était importée au prix de lourdes
pertes
nous sommes ici dans le faubourg hnk qui
était importée par 2 division polonaise
sous le commandement de prince
poniatowski le soir tombe sur la ville
en flammes et les soldats de la grande
armée épuisée s'arrête au pied des
remparts
une fois encore les russes se retire et
laisse derrière eux une ville ravagée
par les incendies qu'ils ont eux même
allumé dans les rangs français cette
victoire a un goût de cendre
un gaulois à l'assaut d'un nid d'aigle
russe une allégorie pour appeler
l'héroïsme des hommes qui s'affrontèrent
ici le coeur de ce square baptisé le
square des héros
difficile d'imaginer que ce paysage
bucolique le 19 août 1812 fut un
terrible champ de bataille en sortant de
smolensk le maréchal ney fond sur
l'arrière-garde russe
ici près du village de valentine agora
les russes se bat avec une ténacité
une détermination qui surprend on
apprendra plus tard que derrière les
combattants c'est toute l'armée russe
qui défilaient par une marche de flan le
soir tombe lorsque l'ennemi ben
retraites les français restent maîtres
des lieux mais juno qui a refusé de
prêter main forte au maréchal ney
s'attire les foudres de napoléon
la route de smolensk à moscou traverse
de vastes plaines devenue inhospitalière
dans leur retraite les russes saccage
des récoltes brûle villes et villages
détruisent tout le 5 septembre 127000
français découvrent enfin l'armée russe
ranger en bataille appuyez sur le
village de borodino ce petit musée est
aujourd'hui au centre du champ de
bataille barclay de taulis et bagues
rations sont maintenant sous les ordres
de kutuzov le nouveau général en chef à
la tête de 140 mille hommes est décidé à
se battre
la proche de moscou ne lui laisse pas le
choix la veille de l'affrontement
napoléon reçoit de paris le portrait de
son fils le roi de rome entre le dit il
a un grenadier
ils voient de très bonne heure un champ
de bataille à 6h30 l'emploi arriver si
là où nous sommes à la batterie et de
chez bardineau la red hot du chear dino
conquise la veille par la division
comptant il dit à son entourage
monsieur voilà le soleil d'austerlitz et
d'ici là il peut embraser d'un seul coup
d'oeil tout la position russe
la gauche les flèches débat gration le
centre la batterie rice qui aujourd'hui
masquée par les arbres et l'ailé droite
de la position russe
derrière lui comme à la parade a tué le
riz la garde impériale
hocine de l'empereur la batterie de la
garde tonnes trois coups
la bataille de moskova qui doit ouvrir
aux français les portes de moscou et
commencer la grande redoute et les
flèches de bagues rations des ouvrages
fortifiés qui vont être l'enjeu de cette
bataille
nous sommes à la gauche de la dispositif
russe dans l'une des flèches débat
gratiot c'est ici la bataille faisait
rage pendant trois heures pendant trois
heures des dizaines de milliers dont
s'affronter ici avec un courage inouï
juste un exemple au milieu de cette
flash là ont eu lieu au moment d'un
combat il y avait un bataillon russe
les français arrivent de tous les côtés
rendez vous les russes crie-t-il mais
pour toute réponse les grenailles russe
croiser les baïonnettes et se font tuer
tous jusqu'au dernier au milieu de cette
flèche imaginez-vous derrière moi toute
la plaine couverte des soldats français
qui marchait sans baisser la tête sous
la mitraille avec un tel courage qui a
provoqué l'admiration même des russes et
le général bagration applaudi l'une des
charges des français c'était la charge 2
57e régiment d'infanterie de ligne avant
de se faire blesser mortellement au
milieu de cette flèche
le monastère du sauveur a été construit
sur l'une des trois flèches de ba
gration là même où le général tout choc
of a trouvé la mort sa femme elle va ce
lieu de paix en 1833 et devint la
première abaisse une vie de prière
guidés par le souvenir du général tout
ce qu'offre ce mari qu'elle avait tant
aimé
très vite les russes sont en mauvaise
posture mais stoïque est résolue il
s'arc boutent avec l'énergie du
désespoir n'est et murat demande à
l'empereur des renforts il faut faire
donner la garde impériale qui emportera
tout comme un torrent mais napoléon a
pris sa décision à huit cent lieues de
france dit il on ne risque pas sa
dernière réserve nous sauver si au pire
de la grande redoute
c'était la clé deux dispositifs plus la
grande redoute était ornée de 24,6 du
gros calibre mais l'artillerie française
a choisi ses traits doute comme
l'objectif privilégié de ces tirs un
véritable orage de feu de faire ça va tu
ici
vers 14 heures l'empereur ordonne de
s'emparer de cette ré doute à tout prix
l'infanterie de jeunes de boire démarche
de front vers les canaux russe les
fantassins français sont décimés par la
mitraille
mais soudain les canons russe se taisent
stupeur dans les rangs mais la fumée
s'est dît si et les français voient des
centaines de kiraz qui brillent au
soleil
c'était des cures à sydney auguste de
colin cours qui sont passés par ici par
là où nous sommes et qui ont sabré les
canonniers russe sur leurs pièces mais
le général auguste de caulaincourt a
payé de sa vie cet exploit seule la nuit
qui tombe viendra arrêter le massacre
44 mille tués ou blessés chez les russes
dont le général baha gration enterrés
ici au coeur de la grande redoute ce
monument français pour ne pas oublier
qu'une pléiade de généraux et 30000
soldats furent mis hors de combat durant
cette horrible bataille une victoire au
goût amer dont furent témoins les dom de
l'église de la nativité
à quelques kilomètres du champ de
bataille mojaïsk aujourd'hui rendue au
culte
cet ancien monastère servi d'hôpital de
campagne napoléon hi-fi soigner
indistinctement russes et français
mais
le 13 septembre dans le village de phily
à l'ombre de moscou une vieillissent bas
servi de cadre au conseil de guerre que
réunit kutuzov la séance est houleuse la
discussion animée mais kutuzov tranche
décision est prise
moscou sera abandonné à son sort de
toute façon l'armée russe n'est plus en
état de faire face aux cent mille hommes
de napoléon
à
la colline des moineaux c'est le nom de
l'endroit qui domine moscou c'est de cet
auteur que les français découvrir leurs
proies
ce lundi 14 septembre 1812 est gravé
dans ma mémoire
la voilà donc enfin à cette ville fameux
s'écrit l'empereur qui ajoute il était
temps le soleil fait briller de mille
couleurs cette grande cité
on se presse se bousculent tout l'armée
battant des mains répète avec transport
moscou moscou comme les marins critères
terre après une longue navigation
aujourd'hui seuls les coupoles dorées du
kremlin rappelle que moscou fut une
ville magique où l'orient et l'occident
communiaient dans le même élan
imperturbable saint basile a pris sa
revanche sur l'histoire et semblent
défier la place rouge un bruyant silence
nous enveloppe la ville et mordre comme
inanimé moscou en ce 15 septembre 1812
est déserte
la koutoubia
c'est le nom de cette tour relié au
kremlin par un pont de briques rouges
ici quelques moscovite éleveurs une
barricade pour tenter de résister à
l'avant garde du roy murat ses canons
qui dorment au coeur du kremlin ce sont
les nôtres frappé du n impérial baptisé
le brave ou la fâcheuse ces pièces crash
est le feu et déchaînez la foudre sur le
champ de bataille
pensif napoléon s'est installé au
kremlin
l'antique palais des arts au milieu de
sa garde on compte ici plus de 300 fut
de canaux français saxe en bavarois
italia
c'est par centaines que les russes ont
récupéré ses pièces abandonné par la
grande armée au cours de l'héroïque
retraite
moscou en feu napoléon se réfugier ici
au palais petrowski
bon
aujourd'hui il abrite l'état-major de
l'armée de l'air russe
j'étais de ceux qui ont escorté
l'empereur jusque là ont laissé derrière
nous des images d'apocalypse
les russes brûler eux mêmes leur ville
je revois encore ces hommes des spectres
ivre d'alcool et de haine
armé de torches danser au milieu des
rues embrasé une vision de l'enfer
construit au xviiie siècle le palais
petrowski resterait à retrouver son
lustre d'antan
cette pièce a servi de chambre à
napoléon dans la nuit du 17 au 18
septembre 1812
et
on
moscou brûle ceci nous présage de grands
malheurs murmure l'empereur en regardant
sa conquête s'évanouir en fumée
ordre est donné de fusiller sur le champ
les incendiaires que l'on capture
m
le monastère novodevitchi et l'actuel
musée de l'architecturé russe du xvième
et xviième siècle il servi de dépôts de
vivres pour la grande armée et une unité
d'artillerie s'y était installé une
affreuse odeur de brûlé des pans de murs
noircis des monceaux de cendres et
quelques maisons et par son milieu des
ruines
c'est tout ce qu'il reste de moscou
détruite à 90% au 299 quai de la moskova
l'orphelinat
c'est l'un des rares bâtiments que les
flammes épargne r la statue de kutuzov
trône devant le musée consacré à la
bataille de borodino que les français
appellent bataille de la moskova
à l'abri des regards dans les réserves
du musée des toiles retrace l'épopée
des tableaux mais aussi des objets
personnels égard est abandonnée par les
français comme ses assiettes ayant
appartenu au prince eugène de
beauharnais les propositions de paix de
napoléon restent lettre morte
l'empereur alexandre s'est muré dans le
silence ce palais monastère construit au
xviie siècle échappe à lui aussi à la
destruction est servi de cantonnement
aux soldats de l'empereur
aujourd'hui il fait office de réserve
pour le musée d'histoire nationale et
c'est là que l'on a retrouvé cette
curieuse cuisine roulante en cuivre qui
parti de paris n'y est jamais retourné
ce flot de voitures roulent sur leninski
prospects c'est l'ancienne route
utilisée par la grande armée lors de son
départ de moscou le 18 octobre 1812
napoléon ayant perdu tout espoir de paix
nous étions plus de 100 milles à prendre
le chemin du retour suivi d'une horde de
voitures en tout genre chargé de notre
fait il faisait beau et le canon tonnait
lorsque nous sommes arrivés à malheureux
slave est un bourg que les français et
les russes se disputèrent avec
acharnement le monastère saint nicolas
de l'île noire est toujours debout
témoin de la bataille de maloya roos la
veille
voilà plein août l'armée française
arrivée l arrivée par cette plante là
c'est là qu'il y avait l'état major de
l'anp frère qui observaient le combat
dans ce monastère là le 24 octobre 1812
l'armée française a rencontré l'armée
russe du maréchal kutuzov donc
l'avant-garde français est arrivé ici à
la veille de la bataille donc le soir de
23 il y avait deux bataillons de général
des lions qui ont occupé la ville et les
russes ont contre attaqué le 24 au matin
les deux bataillons et repliée de la
ville et puis c'est tout la division du
journal des gens qui est entrée en
action
et puis finalement c'était le combat
entre le corps doctorow le corps d'armée
le maréchal kutuzov contre le corps le
quatrième corps d'armée de la grande
armée commandée par jumbo harnais et
finalement après avoir passé plusieurs
fois demain à l'autre la ville bien
rester dans les mains des français
dans ce combat il ya le général de
l'otan le commandant de la 3e division
de la grande armée qui est une heure sur
ce champ d'honneur et son frère qui
était son à des camps étaient aussi tué
à ses côtés
cette victoire nous a laissé un goût
amer même si 18000 français et italiens
ont vaincu 50000 russe confusément nous
sentions que toutes ces batailles
gagnées n'empêcherait pas le pire
malo jaroslaw est est un bourg de
quelques milliers d'âmes défiguré par
les constructions de l'ère soviétique
mais il est fier de ces deux musées qui
conserve la mémoire des événements de
cela devient grave dit l'empereur à
caulaincourt je bats toujours les russes
mais cela ne termine rien à 4km de mal à
iaroslav est le village de gordie n'y a
rien à changer
napoléon accoucher dans l'une de ses
maisons de bois une cabane de tisserands
vieille délabré infecte précise ségur
dans ses mémoires
l'empereur a passé la nuit debout
recevant des rapports et s'interrogeant
sur le parti à prendre
faut-il s'ouvrir la route du sud à coups
de canon ou bien se replier sur smolensk
une nuit terrible de doute d'hésitation
finalement ordre est donné à l'armée de
marché sur smolensk
je marche exactement l'endroit où
l'empereur a failli se faire prendre par
les codecs c'est la quête kilomètres de
mahler a slave est le matin 7 heures du
matin le 25 octobre l'empereur est sorti
de petits villages gornja qui se trouve
à un kilomètre et demi d'ici il est
arrivé au galop entourés par quelques
officiers de la donne ans par les
officiers généraux par caulaincourt rap
et de la dc fort et là il ya une grosse
troupe de cosaques i et qui est sorti et
ses officiers généraux est obligée
d'émettre sabre à la main et se battre à
côté de l'empereur pour protéger contre
les cosaques
il y avait les escadrons de services de
la garde qui vient d'apparaître après
colonel et or qui se distinguer ici
le chef d'escadron causé toutleski de
l'unss et polonais qui s'est distingué
finalement les causes à côté repoussé
avec de lourdes pertes et l'empereur a
pu continuer sa marche
mais cet épisode là quand même influence
beaucoup beaucoup empereur parce que l'a
compris qu' il pouvait être pris par par
les cosaques même on dit qu'être séduit
au delà
l'empereur a commandé à son médecin
particulier de lui faire faire le poison
qui portait toujours sur sa poitrine
pour à l'aller le poison et pour c'est
pas donné
vivant dans les mains de l'ennemi
l'hiver nous a rattrapés de marche
encontre marche
les hommes sont fatigués et les vivres
déjà épuisé
les deux armées se sont retrouvés ici à
vias ma d'un côté milhorat dovic
surnommé le mur aarhus de l'autre le
maréchal ney davo et le prince eugène
l'église de la conception place
ce vieillard est le dernier témoin de
ces affrontements depuis plus d'un demi
siècle cette église abri amusé vantant
les mérites du peuple soviétique
cette maison un peu en dehors du centre
servi de quartier général à l'empereur
sem les vaut à peine un point sur la
carte un petit village perdu entre
viazma et ce pôle est devant nous autour
de nous tout neiges
après une plaine blanche une autre
pleine blanche la nature enveloppe dans
un grand linceul notre armée mourante
nous sommes vaincus par notre conquête
pour la première fois l'aigle baisse la
tête
arrivé à sem les veaux l'armée de
l'empereur s'est résigné à laisser
derrière elles ce qui retardait ça
marche
alors dans ce lac que la neige recouvre
on a jetés pêle-mêle des tonnes d'or des
objets d'art dont la fameuse croix divan
legrand et des armes de collection prise
au kremlin
de récentes mesures scientifiques ont
révélé entre autres que le taux d'argent
dans ce lac est mille fois plus élevé
que la normale
on peut imaginer qu'un jour le lac de
sem les veaux livrera ses secrets
à l'arrière-garde le maréchal ney fait
des miracles de viazma à smolensk
harcelé sans cesse par les cosaques
il s'est battu dix jours entiers le
froid est terrible inhumain la violence
du vent est telle que l'on arrive à
peine à se tenir debout le matin au
bivouac
beaucoup ne se réveille pas on se
console en se disant que là où ils sont
ils n'ont plus froid les murailles de
smolensk
la terre promise pour les soldats de
napoléon resteraient après la seconde
guerre mondiale elles sont à peu près
dans l'état de 1812
situé sur la rive gauche du nièvre la
ville était l'un des grands dépôts de
l'armée
en apercevant les dom dorée de la
cathédrale de la vierge on crie au
miracle
beaucoup quittent les rangs cours se
précipitent
hier la grande armée aujourd'hui un
troupeau mais la gamme impérial veille
et défend les portes de la ville ordre
est donné aux régiments de se reformer
dans les faubourgs
le pain est à ce prix mais rien ou
presque ne sera distribué
sur le nombre smolensk cède le désordre
et par tous les magasins force et livrés
aux pillages
on détruisit en 24 heures les ressources
de plusieurs mois on pia et l'on mourait
de faim
cette armée était sortie de moscou forte
de cent mille combattants
vingt-cinq jours plus tard elle était
réduite à trente six mille hommes
valides suivi de 60000 traînards sans
armes
sur la route d'orcia le village de cross
noyer
le soir tombe lorsqu'arrive l'empereur
il se refuse à croire que toute l'armée
de kutuzov l'attend ici
le 16 novembre 1812
le corps de jeunes beauharnais arrive
sur ce champ de bataille où l'empereur
et déjà ici avec la garde dans la ville
de krasnodar mais russe est arrivé aussi
dans ces régions là c'est presque toute
l'armée russe les kutuzov qui arrive
près des cra soyez donc le corps des
jeunes de barney doit frier la route à
travers les rangs de l'armée russe il
aurait joué à l'empereur mais le 17
c'est le corps de maréchal davout qui
arrive est alors pour les po lyon il
faut absolument faire rebrousser chemin
à la garde et donner la garde pour
laisser passer le corps du maréchal
davout et donc le 17 il ya eu un combat
violent c'est peut-être la plus grande
bataille de la retraite
la bataille des crasses l'oeil est la
division de lasbordes de la jeune garde
a été donné pour la première fois
vraiment à fond ici dans ce ravin
donc les gars n'ont répoussé les russes
ils sont couverts de gloire
pourtant les pertes étaient très lourdes
par exemple le 1er régiment des
voltigeurs a été complètement anéanti
sous la mitraille des canaux russe et
sous les charges d'intérêts des
cuirassiers de général du cac pourtant
ça donnait la possibilité aux corps de
maréchal davout passé naturellement il a
perdu pas mal de personnel a perdu aussi
beaucoup des canons des
deux trains avec des caissons mais quand
même il a pu passer et le 17
l'empereur a compris qu'on ne peut plus
rester ici malgré tout l'héroïsme de
l'armée française les forces n'étaient
pas égal il fallait partir mais à ce
moment là le corps de marshall né n'est
pas encore arrivée sur les champs de
bataille
un peu près vers 3h30 d'après-midi le
maréchal ney est arrivé ici près de ce
ravin le cheminot l'armée russe
l'attendaient déjà de l'autre côté
c'était le général mais l'aura de vichy
avec trois corps d'armée d'infanterie et
avec deux cores décarie avec 40 ou 60
canon il était là le maréchal lannes
avec 6000 hommes et six pièces du canon
hatley la première division qui
marchaient à la tête de marie jeanne et
c'était la division ricard qui
appartenait au corps de maréchal davout
qui s'est ardennes depuis peu en route
ce cette division dès qu'elle est
arrivée ici était écrasée par la retirer
russe est détruite par les charge de la
cavalerie donc n'est ordonné à division
réseaux de monter à l'assaut
donc c'était d'à peu près 2000 personnes
contre trente mille et contre 40 pièces
des canaux ils en disent ont traversé le
ravin ils ont monté toujours sous le feu
des canons russe accablé par la
mitraille mais quand même il continue à
monter toujours ils ont arrivés presque
vers le bouche des canaux russe mais l'a
écrasée par la mitraille est attaqué par
la cavalière et russes par l'infanterie
russe la division radio a été presque
anéanti et très poussée mais cet
héroïsme des soldats de cette division 1
termine en maréchal ney des deux
crochets et de faire sa retraite
nous ne sommes pas bien dinet
qu'allez-vous faire répondit l'un de ses
officiers passé le dniepr où elle chemin
nous le trouverons et s'il n'est pas
gelé il le sera répondu de maréchal
le dieppe était juste gelé pour
permettre une traversée à pied
il a fallu abandonner à l'ennemi
l'artillerie les bagages et les blessés
qui ne pouvait pas marcher
c'est ici près du village de sirocco rue
nier que le maréchal ney et ses hommes
échappés taurus arrivé à harcha napoléon
prévoyant le pire fit brûler ses papiers
c'est dans cette maison qu'il passa la
nuit et qu'il apprit que le maréchal ney
été sauvé aujourd'hui c'est une prison
désaffectée
le dégel qui nous accompagnent le nous
ait d'aucun secours
les routes sont glissantes les chemins
défoncés et la bérézina charrie des
normes glaçons
la bérézina c'est ici que tout ce jour
durant trois jours et trois nuits
l'empereur est parmi nous ne nous quitte
pas cela suffit pour que nous jetions
nos ultimes forces dans la bataille
studio 2k le village est resté tel qu en
ce monument à rappelle aux russes
comment ils forçaient relais français
dans les eaux glacées du fleuve
les mêmes maisons de bois dont les
rondins servir aux sapeurs de l'armée en
retraite pour jeter leurs ponts sur la
bérézina
nous sommes exactement dans l'endroit où
il y avait le pont qu'ils étaient
construits par les contenir des général
blaise et ponts ont été construits dans
la nuit de 25 à 20 6 novembre pour le
passage l'artillerie riziki plage le
point était terminé définitivement vers
16 heures et à partir de ce moment là
les troupes on a commencé le passage à 4
100 m 10 sieverts vers le nord il y
avait l'autre pont construit pour
l'infanterie et ce pont là était
terminée vers 13h20 6 novembre et aussi
tout de suite on a commencé le passage
il faut imaginer que dans dans ses
berges là il y avait des milliers et des
milliers d'hommes un masseur hamas et il
y avait des centaines des canons des
chariots tout était ici sur ce bord là
de la rivière la grande arme a été prise
en tenaille par des forces supérieures
des russes mais heureusement le général
kutuzov il avancé assez lentement et
donc c'était que deux armées russes
l'armée de wittgenstein tchaïkovski
attaquer ici le général kutuzov et le
tait à trois journées démarche ici
sur l'autre rive
les russes attendait les français au
milieu des labours
les cuirassiers de doux merck surgissant
des bois sabres r les fantassins du dard
avec le courage du désespoir
oh
nous sommes au pied du monument qui
était construit la mémoire des régiment
des chasseurs russes qui ont participé à
la bataille de bérézina ici dans cet
endroit même ses chasseurs russes qui
sont sortis du bois qui est derrière moi
sont allés vers le pont de bérézina pour
couper pour ne pas laisser passer
l'armée française mais dans l'armée
française il y avait encore de la
cavalerie
cette cavalerie qui venait du corps du
maréchal oudinot c'était la division du
cuirassier du général de merck et
maréchal ney roux donné la charge la
division de merck a chargé et ici
notamment dans cet endroit là c'est le
dix-septième cuirassiers qui a chargé
les trois régiments à des chasseurs
russes donc à peu près 300 cuirassiers
français contre 3000 4000 inquiétant
russes et les cuirassiers ans réussit
quand même des sabres est l'ennemi est
comme ça sauve et l'armée qui passait la
bérézina
et